you know to a whole new place what is
this time span that we're looking at
that you got engaged from january
started talking february met in person
got engaged i'm backing you you're
[ __ ] crazy
you're [ __ ] you could you could have
ended up in a body bag you are [ __ ]
like no and i watch all those things so
don't don't do what i did better don't
do what i did that is cool i'm the
exception just for that moment did any
of your personal friends what the [ __ ]
are you doing yeah they were kind of
worried but let me tell you this okay so
then we got engaged i went back to korea
he was like you should be here i was
like okay and five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast we
have a very special guest a very long
time friend
jennifer chung hi
it is my honor to be here
long time friend long time listener
totally i'm always like randomly like
texting him or putting it on stories
like this is so good you know what i
actually uh i never got to hear from you
i never got to hear uh the full story of
how you met john
okay so john's my husband we've been
married now eight years
4 20 is actually our anniversary and
i'll tell you this just to preface this
when when she told me how she met this
man i was like don't you [ __ ] marry
this guy all right it's [ __ ] punpet
like don't you know by the way i met him
this guy's fantastic
what a fantastic man well just the the
the scope of how it started was a little
precarious especially from the outside
as a friend it's like who the [ __ ] is
this guy yeah no all my friends were
like okay do we stop this from happening
we do trust your judgment but we don't
know anything about him
so
long story kind of short i was living in
k-town at the time darkest time of my
life okay i always say that there's like
a dark cloud following me when i lived
in la but i had this opportunity to go
to korea through a show called like
superstar k
and like preface i've heard terrible
stuff yes i did not want to ever like be
like a k-pop star but i was so depressed
in la that i was like okay i'll take the
round-trip flight to korea yeah and like
in america it's only me my mom my
brother like biologically related right
for family and i was like you know what
i could go to korea see my family
my grandma my grandpa i didn't really
have a relationship with my dad i hadn't
seen him in 10 years at that point yeah
but i was like i'll take the opportunity
to go to korea but you know in like
those shows they try to make you really
sad and like cry about like not making
it forward so i remember like the moment
that i got kicked off i was like pretty
happy
and they were like aren't you sad that
you can't do this anymore i'm like no
like i got to come to korea now i get to
see family they obviously did not use
that footage but it was my way of like
getting out of la i ended up like seeing
my dad and reconciling with him and
there was a lot of things that i didn't
know that i had to reconcile but
wait so because i know like you said
your mom was
actually i don't know anything about
your dad yeah this is a part of your
life i actually yeah i just know that
your mom
is in the bay area yeah and she's a
dance instructor so what you're so what
your parents split early on or was he
not yeah they they split when i was like
five years old also super young yeah
super young he went to korea yeah
so
my dad had like a radio dj job that he
was supposed to do in san francisco okay
um you know in the korean like radio
market
and when my parents split he was like i
can't make a living here like i have to
go back to korea
um so we would my brother and i would
travel to korea every summer until i was
like a freshman in high school and
that's why i hadn't seen him for 10
years
oh [ __ ] but was he at least like
somewhat present in your guy's life
not really not really like it was always
a tumultuous thing when it came to like
money and like child support and all
these things so my mom was pretty
independent when it came to that um but
you know like when you don't grow up
with a kid i don't know like if you know
how to communicate with them because you
grow so much and they have this image of
you as
a child
so those are things that like made the
tension bigger and here's the thing like
i know that there are people who have
like daddy issues and all these things
but for me it was really just i never
grew up with him
so it wasn't even like i need someone to
fill that spot that's empty i just
didn't know what it was like to grow up
with a dad yeah yeah yeah yeah so when i
went to korea i didn't think that i was
going to actually see my dad but my dad
lives in a town called isan in korea
outside his house and that's just
happened to be where the show was being
filmed and when we got kicked off it was
like two in the morning and the only
person that picked me up was my dad oh
[ __ ] yeah so i ended up staying with him
and then i was like he was like this is
your home too you know like you could
stay here as long as you want i was like
yeah because my round trip ticket to
back to america i could take it any time
within a year okay so i was like yeah
i'll just like stay in korea because i i
don't know what the heck i'm doing
anymore oh [ __ ] yeah and so i ended up
staying with him
and
getting to know who he was and also
putting the pieces together on the
things that my mom had told me about him
and figuring out myself right was that
weird though i mean because i only think
about it like this right it's like
i like i don't know how you navigated
your childhood with with not having a
father there knowing where he is because
it's not like he bounced and you didn't
know where he was at yeah it's like i
know where this [ __ ]
is and then he comes in he enters his
life and he goes my house is your house
it's like what the [ __ ] guy yeah how i
see it anyways in my head because i'm a
very spiteful person i'm like what the
[ __ ] do you mean like yeah what is this
thing and it's weird because
we probably know this mutual person too
but she was on that show as well and
when she got kicked off this girl
doesn't speak any korean sure opened up
the door said leave and this left her
out it's like the [ __ ] yeah i don't know
i don't know for me i felt like it was
very divine that i just happened to be
in the city where my father was and i
had to call him up and
live with him and like learn who he was
and establish a relationship with him
outside of what my mom would say yeah or
what my grandparents would say and
really get to know him as a person and
you know as you get older you have more
grace and understanding of how your
parents are yeah um so i was really just
figuring him out
and at that time i was like you know
figuring out what i was going to do i
ended up almost signing as like an indie
artist in korea with another label and
like doing radio shows like the um
korean-american ones where they have
like you know english-speaking audiences
yeah teaching english i was just
grinding and living in
his son
and it was during that time when i was
still kind of dabbling in youtube and
posting youtube videos here and there
but at that point i really didn't
consider myself a youtuber yeah it was
just i've had my channel for so long i
still want to share myself singing
and um i posted on instagram oh like i
like that i uploaded a new song and i
noticed that
someone um liked my
photo but you know like you have random
followers so you don't think much of it
yeah but i looked at it and the profile
photo was like a vintage picture of a
korean guy and i was like oh i wonder if
i know him because all koreans kind of
know each other yeah yeah i look at his
profile and i'm like oh he's from
atlanta
i don't know he's kind of handsome oh i
could see that he goes to church oh he
seems to do music yeah uh i don't know
him but like what's the worst that could
happen right like he's not going to come
to korea and kill me
who knows who knows
maybe they will but in this situation i
was being very bold
so i actually like scrolled all the way
down and saw a like picture of him and
his mom
and i was like oh i couldn't help but
like this picture
and he and then he was like oh thanks i
really like your thinking of you um
thinking about you cover
and then that's a og one yeah very old
and so we he there was no dms at that
point okay so it wasn't even sliding
into dm's comments
and then i was like oh this is my email
if you ever want to link up and maybe do
music because i saw that he worked at a
recording studio
and i've collaborated on music with
people i've never met before yeah um
just abroad
so we ended up messaging each other and
then i told him like oh if you ever want
to connect i have cacao right yep
talk and um
he's in atlanta and i'm in korea but the
thing is at the time he was working at a
recording studio as a night manager and
engineer and he was working the night
shift so it just happened to work out
that he would be awake when i'm awake oh
okay yeah so i think he'd go into work
at like 9 00 p.m and come out at like
six seven in the morning okay so we
would always be communicating but that
first week we just couldn't stop talking
to each other and at the end of the week
we're like oh i think we're supposed to
be together
right so that was january of 2013
and then we were like you know we need
to be certain that this is supposed to
happen so maybe i'll come visit you in
february yeah
so
um i was like okay i'm gonna go visit
you know georgia but how am i gonna make
this happen
but i like just put it on facebook is
there anyone that could get me like a
buddy pass or something or cheap flights
to georgia yeah and a family friend was
like i could get you a buddy pass like
um cheap ticket to san francisco and i'm
from the bay area so i was like okay i
could see my mom before and after i meet
this guy yeah and john took care of my
flight from san francisco to georgia
but the thing is i was like okay it was
a very affordable ticket it was only
like 500 from korea to san francisco
round trip damn it's hella cheap yeah um
it was buddy pass so um i was like okay
but 500 is still a lot to spend on
someone you don't know oh 100 right so i
was like okay god if you want this to
happen like make it undeniable
and i kid you not as soon as i purchase
a ticket i get a call
from like a pastor in korea who is like
throwing this like fundraiser and stuff
and they were like we want to hire you
to sing
and you just have to sing one song and
we're going to pay you a thousand
dollars oh [ __ ] so it would cover my
flight yeah i was like okay you want me
to go see this guy yeah
so the flight was taken care of
and i end up flying to georgia
and okay wait but backtrack even though
we didn't have a lot of mutual friends
we had one mutual friend and that's the
mutual friend i met during the shooting
of superstar k
oh
so i asked him what do you think of this
guy
and he's like oh
he's a great guy yeah shout out to andy
okay so he was the one that said
he's a good guy okay and i feel like
when a guy friend tells you that a guy
is solid it feels like yeah because you
know sometimes guys could be really nice
to girls yeah when like guys can be
homies yeah yeah yeah it co-signed for
me so i flew to georgia we met that week
i met his family because it just
happened to be his nephew's birthday we
got engaged that week that's crazy no
ring
just a promise
right because we were broke like we were
just like struggling artists
fly back to korea
and then i'm like
he's like oh you should be here and i'm
like yeah but we're not married yet like
i'm not trying to move for a boyfriend
you know
a whole new place what is this time span
that we're looking at that you got
engaged from january
started talking february met in person
got engaged i'm backing you you're
[ __ ] crazy
you're [ __ ] you could you could have
ended up in a body bag you are [ __ ] i
know and i watch all those things so
don't don't do what i did that is don't
do what i did that is the exception just
for that moment did any of your personal
friends what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah
they were kind of worried but let me
tell you this okay so then we got
engaged i went back to korea he was like
you should be here i was like okay let's
just get married okay
so i fly back to san francisco
um and we actually get married in san
jose at my mom's church my mom had just
become a christian so they're like you
have to get married in the church
because we didn't have money for a
wedding yeah church marriage are the
cheapest so we were like we i honestly
just wanted to do um like courthouse
marriage but they were like no you have
to get married at the church so all her
friends did the flowers for me i got my
wedding dress the week before my friends
found their bridesmaid dresses at zappos
like
you know super quick
and so um we got married on 4 20 because
that was the only day that the church
was available
so january february april we got married
within four months of knowing each other
right insane and my my husband's
mom is also also a single mom because um
his dad passed away when he was younger
so it's like imagine like our moms just
meet each other for the first time the
night before yeah yeah and so we got
married we actually got into an argument
like the night before and i was like
crying and my friends were like
this is a good idea what did you guys
argue about um
okay so i was
okay i have no secrets with him right
yeah and i had like logged on to my
facebook messenger
on his laptop but he looked at it and he
saw that i was talking to
um like
of mine and talking to him about john
yeah and he it really offended him that
i was talking to him about him and that
thing is he doesn't know he doesn't know
my relationship with his oppa right
and it was a good lesson learned that
like i don't necessarily need a lot of
like close guy friends but in my defense
like he was like my brother before like
he was john was anyone in my life well i
have a different take on that too my
thing is like
if you enter my life prior to
after this person you have no say yeah
because i've established this
relationship before you around yeah and
at that point when we when i just
started dating somebody yeah they asked
me who's more important they are yeah
because you just entered here totally
like that's how i feel anyways
and that's what mariel and i figured out
with her too i told her like any person
that you've known before me guy girl it
doesn't matter you vo you i you've had
that relationship you've never been
together with them you've there's no
explanation needed yeah but i don't
because i don't have that so it's cause
it's weird because i have a lot of
friends who are girls and she knows this
and if it's like some new role that came
into my life and then she was at the
house that's a little weird yeah you
know and then we're having conversations
it's like
i i would feel a little odd too but
somebody who's been established in my
life for years i have nothing to care
about because they've been around for
years and they've never hooked up or
anything so what the [ __ ] the point i
think it was like that added pressure of
like okay this is the night before the
wedding and he was probably like getting
into his head about stuff oh for sure i
mean you guys are moving things really
fast like i'm very sympathetic towards
john like i understand like she's crazy
like i would you know he doesn't know
how to deal with you know you're getting
married you just met this girl he's
madly in love this is who's this [ __ ]
guy like what's going on you know no and
so that's why my friends were like what
you just cried uh do you should we stop
the wedding and at this point i am such
a i don't want to inconvenience people
and i'm like everyone's already here so
like let's just get this wedding over
with and figure it out after that's
crazy
so we ended up you know making it work
and like fast forward to eight years now
like we're a lot happier now yeah but we
started with like no ring he surprised
me with a
wedding band and everything like after
and
it's been a blessing but it's a lot of
work for sure i mean you guys also have
uh what's what was the age gap that you
guys are right now five years so i was
23 when i got married yeah okay so you
could do the math on how old i am but um
i was 23 he was 28. so it was really out
of time to where he didn't have to get
married 28 still young still super young
yeah and we were just figuring it out
but there's just something really
special about a guy feeling like yes
like i want you to be my wife and i'm
like okay could you imagine if that was
the wrong guy though no i think god
every day that he ended up not being a
[ __ ] person no and the thing is we
didn't even talk about politics thank
god like we stand in the same way yeah
and like have the same beliefs and our
passion about the same things but
you know even in the past year i know so
many people have gotten divorced and
we've been to their weddings and it's i
understand though because marriage is
really hard 100 but coming from a
divorced family i knew going into this
that like if i was gonna end the
marriage it's not the end of my life i
know that yeah but if i'm going to call
it quits like i need to know i did
everything i possibly could yeah and the
first couple years were really hard and
i would have like conversations with
john about
we're really different yeah we're very
different people but we're together for
a reason and let's at least like try our
best so that we can walk away from it
knowing like we're at peace so within
that okay this is crazy because like
your your guys's relationship story is
so nuts because you do everything that i
advise against
you know because typically when you hear
the story it never ends up like this
sure and i know and i'm not saying this
from just
me guessing i'm saying a majority of
people that have come to me with the
same thing have always end up in hot
disaster which is very very odd it's
super odd just because you don't really
get to know somebody until you're really
around them yeah we don't even know our
friends like that until like
seven or eight or nine or ten years
later so like when we start opening up
to somebody who's supposed to be a very
important part of our lives such as our
husband or wife there are things that
you're gonna find out that you might
dislike a lot and we did find a lot of
things yeah what was like the biggest
discrepancy that you guys had when you
when you first after you got married
what is something that you found out
about him that you were like oh [ __ ]
um a couple things just our interests
were very different like i was a theater
major i loved disney i grew up listening
to musicals um he was a hip-hop head
yeah
georgia you know atlanta and another big
thing was how he handled money okay yeah
and even though we both grew up with
like single moms our situations were
very different like for him he lost his
dad but his dad was very successful
worked really hard his mom worked really
hard to like be able to raise them um
for me like my mom worked really hard
but we were poor our whole life because
she was a dance teacher she's an artist
yeah like we grew up with like
government aid our whole life um and
like i was very fearful of debt and like
also scarcity mentality in terms of like
i need to take care of myself yeah like
how can i help other people when i can't
even help myself
um but we had to find a way where we
could bridge those things because there
can also be really detrimental
generosity right yes you're just and
also you have to question like am i
being generous because i love being
generous or am i being generous because
i want people to know that i'm generous
and i think we had to like find ways on
like how can we be generous with people
if we can't be generous with um
necessarily money how can we be helpful
with resources or time
for our skills
so we've been able to establish that but
that took time
yeah but i i always tell people like i
think the best thing about our marriage
was that we started with nothing
our marriage we didn't send anything on
the wedding we've been to some of the
most lavish most beautiful weddings and
they did not make it yeah right so for
us it's very much been like okay we're
in this we're gonna be partners we're
gonna figure this out and like to be
able to say like we've been able to
slowly grow
um our business and also like what we
have like it's fine because all of that
is extra
we've been able to do a lot with little
i mean fighting is such a
it's such a tactic especially when it
comes to relationships it's like man how
do i communicate with this person
without punching them in the face
no it's real like it's like [ __ ] man
especially because you guys said you
guys grew up so differently and you guys
think differently the communication
style must have been very difficult yeah
because mary and i are very different
and our communication style is
completely [ __ ] different so it's
just a matter of like
it's it's literally just limbo all the
time right i feel like we're just too
clumsy people trying to navigate through
a conversation until we find good
balance it's like okay what the [ __ ] is
what are your trigger words what are
your trigger things that you do or don't
say yeah like i found out recently don't
ever say that she is very similar to her
mom
and that is a death sentence sure yeah
and i'm like oh [ __ ] yeah you know but
then i i use that as an example of like
okay if there are things that you don't
like that your mom does then try not to
be like that yeah but that what she
hears is oh you say i'm just like my mom
yeah then it's like boom this huge fight
right so there's like all these trigger
words that we're finding out and it's
just it gets it gets exhausting so when
you guys argue like who would you say is
the one that like wants to let's figure
this out right now well that's me yeah
because my family deals with it like
that yeah we we always deal with
problems head-on yeah so and we don't we
don't have lingering feelings i don't
believe in lingering feelings yeah she's
the type of person that when we fight
if we fight and things get very
tumultuous right and mind you it's been
we haven't had like a major fight and
you know i know a lot of people say this
but it's been like since like
the last time we had here's what was
like february it's been quite a while
yeah
very [ __ ] long time
because she's been going through therapy
so and i've been going to therapy and
then we've been figuring stuff out so
i'm like damn it's been a hot second
since we actually had a huge fight yeah
but
it would be
back in the day and i'm talking about
back in the day which was like six years
and only seven years we in the seventh
year we have five but then 2020 like
felt like five years oh for sure well
this is we actually started fighting a
lot during pandemic yeah because i have
never had to be around her this long
i should you not within this year alone
when pandemic started in this year so
it's been about a year and a half i
spent more time with her in a year and a
half than i have in six years with her
prior
so i didn't really know her very well
right so
when we were stuck together and i have
to see her every day i have to see the
way that she talks how she behaves how
she interacts with things how she is
working with somebody like that
she was pissing me off 24 7 and i was
pissing her off 24 7. right and for me i
didn't know these certain habits i she
didn't know how i work right and i think
sometimes for her she's just we want
people to behave the way that we would
handle certain things and so we kind of
put this unnecessary pressure on each
other all the time and so what we found
out is that okay there are a lot of
issues that we have that we haven't
addressed because we didn't see it six
years together and you don't know you
tell me you [ __ ] married this guy in
four months
are you insane
no yeah it was major faith but okay
actually it's funny that we we're
talking about fighting because it was
that first weekend i met him in february
i was staying with him and then we had
gone to our first argument it had to do
with music because we're both musicians
and it was a foreshadow of how difficult
it would be to work together yeah right
because we're artists are sensitive and
we have our different points of views
and we got into our first fight about it
but i remember he told me even before we
met in person like when i'm upset i need
space yep so after the argument i gave
him space and like imagine me this is my
first time meeting this guy and he's
like locked in his office like taking
his space because we've gone to argument
so i'm just sitting there like
this sucks like i'm leaving this weekend
and this is what's happening in the
middle of the week so i decided to write
him a letter just saying like i'm sorry
that we fought but i'm really thankful
that i'm experiencing this and actually
seeing like oh you said you needed space
and i can see that this is this is what
you need but i'm really grateful that we
met and i hope that we have like a good
time for the rest of the week yeah and
so i sent him i gave him that letter i
just like left it out and then i went to
sleep and then that in the middle of the
night he woke me up and asked me to
marry him after reading that oh wow yeah
so that's why i was like but i remember
like thinking like what
i'm so tired like he's just woke me up
to ask me to marry him no ring and i
remember thinking like in my head like
how is this guy who's like living in a
house with roommates
like not and he doesn't have a ring for
me gonna take care of me like yeah you
know just like the of course we think
about that we think about security
especially when you grow up in an
unstable household without stable income
because your whole thing is like i want
to live differently from my parents yeah
you know and but i remember hearing a
voice this is gonna sound crazy but i
heard a voice saying like oh you think
he's gonna take care of you
and i am a woman of faith and i wouldn't
consider myself like charismatic where
like speaking in tongues and stuff none
of us but there was just something in me
that was saying oh you think he's going
to take care of you and that was
affirmation to me like at the end of the
day it's god that's going to cover me
and so i said yes
and like it's been working out ever
since that's [ __ ] crazy i can't
imagine that [ __ ] yeah like i i can't
imagine
being with somebody in that short of
time and being like hey god got me
you know that i'm like don't need it no
but i'm telling you when i say like l.a
k-town was my darkest days i remember
like i'd visit your old place in k-town
yeah like i'd be happy to see you but
deep down inside like i was just like
struggling like how can i live here and
like do music i was working so many jobs
i always remember yeah i was working as
a tutor i was working as a receptionist
i was doing all these things just so i
could do music yeah um and i remember it
got to the point where i would like date
like stupid dudes and in my mind i would
i started like really figuring out who i
was and early on i know other people
would be freaked out by it but like we'd
start dating and maybe like on date
through i'd be like so what are you
doing here
what's what's the point of this yeah and
they'd be like we're getting to know
each other like we're dating and i'm
like i just need to know if you see a
future with me yeah i don't need you to
ask me to marry me like but i need to
know like do you see me as your wife
because if not like we're not gonna do
this yeah so i would easily cut off
people very quickly yeah
and i think that helped me actually in
terms of like knowing whether or not
someone was in it because i know so many
people who have been in long-term
relationships that like just didn't work
out yeah but you're a little too young
to talk like that yeah that's just scary
as [ __ ] so yeah yeah ladies don't do
that
yeah you might scare me [ __ ] out of
somebody but you also might attract the
right person yeah but most likely you
won't
like that's like some people that when
they're like 50 years
years
old
and then now i see like young and so i'm
like no like stay single enjoy it i joke
with john like you took my best years my
youthful years but we'll be like walking
and the pandemic for us was very healing
because it gave us moments like take
pause and really spend time together as
family we have two pitbulls we were just
like walking them all the time and he
was just like man
i don't know what i was expecting from
you at 23. yeah cause like you know even
him he had like that korean misogyny
still ingrained in him in the sense of
like oh you got to be cooking for me
like new meals every day i'm like i
barely know how to take care of myself
and now i have to take care of you but
obviously like when you learn how to
like have a home and like cook and you
enjoy it like your marriage just gets
better because your life's getting
better yeah but there was like a time of
like having to learn
how to do life together and not have so
many expectations yeah like the biggest
issue that a lot of people have when
they get together and i didn't realize
this until i started being together with
people because i have a very strong um
i think like one of my best attributes
is an idea of family i grew up in a
crazy family right but we always were a
strong family yeah if we suffered we all
suffered together yeah if we were if if
somebody felt bad everybody felt bad if
we all felt good we all built each other
up even if things were crazy my mom was
a psychopath my dad was [ __ ] crazy we
had terrible problems but we always
cared about the family unit so
the reason why i bring that up is that a
lot of people don't understand and this
is what i truly believe i know i know
this is a [ __ ] fact if you want a
[ __ ] healthy household you got to
stop thinking about me you got to think
about the us that's real so when you
create a meal you're not doing you're
not doing it saying i'm making dinner
for you i made a meal for us yes that's
what it is yeah you're feeding your
family when you clean up the floor you
take out the trash i didn't take out the
trash i took out the trash for this
household this is how tasks should be
done right and it might turn out that oh
you do it all the time well guess what
somebody should be able to pick up the
slack somewhere else in the house we
don't look at stuff like their favorites
and their tasks it's like this is my
duty in order to have a healthy
household this is how things should be
done and it was hard for i think
marielle's therapist kind of mentioned
that to her because i couldn't explain
to her
what it was that i expected right and
what i mean by that is not for her to do
the dishes do the laundry or whatever
but it's like if there's something that
you feel needs to get done the way that
you want it to get done you should
handle it because no matter how i do it
it's going to be disappointing yeah so
don't look at it as a task of oh when i
do the laundry i have to do yours too i
don't think about it no no like for and
i gave her an example i was like oh [ __ ]
when i pay for the utilities of this
house and i pay for vacations i have to
pay for yours too i was like have i ever
thought of it like that or do i think
hey when i go on vacation i'm gonna take
my partner with me when i clean this car
i want her to have a nice car when i uh
[ __ ] i don't know uh build [ __ ]
that's gonna break obviously because i
suck at it like i do it because i do it
because it needs to be done yes so we
don't look at things like testing when
we think about us as a family unit and i
think a lot of people before they kind
of get into these long-term
relationships they only
consistently think about the me and they
haven't transitioned into us part that's
right us part is hard for people because
they always feel that when they do
something is a favor it's like i'm doing
you a favor when am i gonna get my favor
back it's like don't think that think
that i'm doing something for us yes and
it doesn't feel like a chore anymore
yeah you know i know finances is such a
sensitive topic for a lot of people
and especially in relationships and i
think like the biggest remedy was really
thinking like you know especially as
creatives or entrepreneurs your monthly
income looks different every month
so there are going to be months when
like you make more money than your
partner vice versa so instead of like
feeling like oh i owe more it's more
this is what we made as a unit this
month and then see
continuing to think about that 100 i
mean the money part is so sensitive
right for a lot of people for me it's
not so bad because like
i think like the struggle that mariel
might have is that
because she holds on to her independence
it's actually a trait that i really like
about her but the part that sometimes
that we might get into trouble with is
where
she doesn't have an issue that i'd make
more money but it's more like she still
wants to be somebody that could stand on
her own sure and i'm sure she can she
can 100 if i died tomorrow she's still
flying you know
uh financially and so for me i don't
really think about that i'm just more
like okay so what we found out was
and we talked about it on a podcast that
we had before i shouldn't put that one
out yet but i'll put it out um
i'm like please do cause all this
it was kind of this idea of what money
means in our relationship right
and so what i mean by that is
she thought that i felt that uh i
undervalued her effort because i can
repair things in our relationship with
money that i have right
and what so here's an example it was
like
oh we couldn't clean this house so and
i'm like i can't clean this house this
week and she was like i'm well sunday
let's just forget the stuff that we have
to do it's going to be stressful but
let's just clean this house all sunday
i'm like no
you and i are busy you have projects
that you want to do i'm busy with work
how about i just
get a cleaner i'll pay them like 150
bucks 180 bucks and they'll clean the
whole house first and you know she
stopped and she said no i want you to do
it and i want me to do it and i'm like
that no that doesn't make any sense we
don't have time i was like
either way whenever i clean something
you think i do a terrible job so how
about we just find this cleaner and then
what we found out later on was that the
reason why is because she assumed that
the value of my money was worth more
than her effort
and that's how she was value evaluating
it i think i recall you talking about
this in a podcast actually and i said
like well no that's not what it is it's
your value of your work is here my money
is here and i use money to to match up
match you up you have it twisted the
other way around and so for her it's
just about its personal value that gets
affected
[Music]
i turned my back on the things i knew
fell in love you know it got me confused
i was young i was filled with fire the
smoke was just getting higher
fell hot i was hurting bruised it was at
this time that i became recluse the
cards were dealt and i played broke the
rules so i couldn't stay chasing the
wind hoping you win
but you learn that it burns
and it won't stay for no one
[Music]
where did all the people go
all the ones that i had known
you moved too fast and then you're gone
i've been away for so long i don't know
where i belong
[Music]
i've been away for so long i don't know
where i belong
i don't know where i belong
[Music]
where i belong
[Music]
i woke up and i caught the time too many
years gone by and i can't rewind
do i come to mind the way you do mine
the way you're doing lost track of what
i felt i moved these from west and i
thought i'd find it
though i left the memory stay
even if the details fade chasing the
wind hoping you'll win
but you learn that it burns
and it won't stay for no one
where did all the people go
all the ones that i had known you move
too fast
i've been away for so long i don't know
where i belong
[Music]
i've been away for so long i don't know
where i belong
i don't know where i belong
[Music]
where i belong
i don't know where i'll be here
[Applause]
[Music]
i woke up and i caught the time two
minutes gone by and i can't reply
[Music]
this podcast is brought to you by raycon
raycon earbuds are my go-to choice
whenever i am listening to a podcast
whenever i'm at the gym or i'm just
taking walks i don't go anywhere without
my raikons my friends they start at half
the price of other premium audio brands
but honestly sound just as good and the
best thing about them is that they have
a 32 hour goddamn battery life so i can
listen to them when i want for a really
long time especially when i'm traveling
and i'm on a plane if you've had
wireless earbuds and their batteries die
super fast it's super annoying when
you're traveling on a plane because you
have to recharge it and then while
you're recharging for like 20 or 30
minutes to an hour you have no music no
movies or nothing so create
your own soundtrack with raycon right
now my genius brain listeners can get 15
off their raycon order at byraycon dot
com slash brain that's by recon dot com
slash brain to say 15
on raycon's that's by raycon.com
brain it's like doesn't my effort matter
i was like yeah your effort [ __ ]
matters but i clean like [ __ ]
and i think it kind of like translates
into like the love languages thing you
know acts of service versus like gifts
or like all those things and like
finding communication ways of like what
people accept because people may accept
love differently than they give too yeah
100 and she she assumes that she at the
time anyways that she was a words of
affirmation person and that's like her
tertiary one she's actually an active
service person yeah john is also active
service yeah and so like i was like i
could do that you can ask john about
this when he comes in town but
we hired we had to hire cleaners too
yeah because i don't clean the way that
he wants you to come exactly so but he
likes it a certain way but he doesn't
always have time and i don't always have
time so it's been a game changer for us
to have cleaners come like we clean here
and there but when he needs a deep ass
totally because we have two dogs like it
gets wild yeah and then when they when
they come in this place looks brand
[ __ ] new i was like there's no way
that i'm gonna do this i cannot do this
and they're they're professionals yeah
like oh my god i'm like hey how'd you do
that i was like she was like i just do
it i'm like yeah but how'd you do it
though like how did you clean this this
makes no sense and as soon as they leave
you know it's just the smell yeah crisp
smell it smells so [ __ ] good is that
you know the idea of compromise is hard
for people too and like
the compromise part that people kind of
[ __ ] up onto that i realize
is the idea that when you compromise you
are giving something up right and you're
going and both you have to lower
yourself to meet this thing it's like no
you're actually taking something away to
level up it's the other way around it
goes this way it's like oh i don't need
this as much you don't need this as much
now we're here but people look at it the
other way around where they feel like
they're losing something and they have
to compromise and you know go lower than
what they originally expected which is
the exact opposite that's real like the
transition from me to we is like a huge
partnership agreement that you have to
have and we always say like you know
when people ask like oh how have you
been able to make your marriage survive
this long
it's really just choosing each other
every day yeah like that practice
because it's easy to just be like one
day like i'm just going to choose me and
do what i want to do yeah and yeah it
might not like ruin the whole marriage
or relationship forever that one day but
that adds up yeah and like to be able to
say like oh i'm looking to this person
i'm going to choose them even like when
they're having a bad day you know that's
the hard part it's like when you when
you choose to be around somebody that
you care about when you see them at
their worst it's very difficult like
just this past weekend we were biking
and muriel was [ __ ] bitching for
[ __ ] four hours straight biking is
this [ __ ] i hate this i hate that
and then off we went to go eat and she
was like i'm really glad i biked today
and i'm like let me tell you something
this is the worst experience of my life
how dare she's just cracking up she goes
yeah i was really annoying i'm like yeah
my god are you really annoying dude yeah
but that's a blessing to be able to have
someone who will hear you out and she
was like well she was like well why'd
you do it i was like you know what cuz i
[ __ ] know you i know that you had a
heavy ass breakfast and if you didn't
bike this thing off you would have been
like i feel so fat i feel like this i
was like i'm gonna hear that all day
that's why i forced you to bike and now
you feel [ __ ] great it's like right
and she goes yeah it's like you know me
so well i was like yeah i had to suffer
for four hours but yeah now you feel
great now excuse me i'm gonna take a
[ __ ] nap no but i love that you're
normalizing and like being open about
like having therapists individually
because that's also been really helpful
for us too oh sh
yeah she she we talked about on the
podcast where you know we had a very
huge fight and
for her my ultimatum for her was like i
needed to try therapy yes because i
can't i can't talk to you what a healthy
suggestion too yeah it was like you have
to do this i was like it was an
ultimatum like if you don't try
something outside of like your normal
circle group and me yeah because
obviously what we say
it affects you differently because you
feel like you're being judged well talk
to somebody who's impartial right and i
don't and i think when people think
about therapy sometimes they view it as
like somebody comes in and they tell you
how to live your life and that's not
what it is it's really just somebody
that's going to listen and give you
suggestions and then you you're smart
enough to figure it out on your own yeah
and so she found a therapist that she
really really likes that she cares about
and it helps her assess things and it
helps her help her communicate with me
and so
the the fact that she did that really
helped save our relationship because if
that didn't happen we wouldn't be
together right now yeah because i was i
already had i already had like talk
about foot out there i was already out
the door like at that point in our
relationship if she left me i would have
been fine because it's so easy to look
at issues and be like ugh that person
that other person is really ruining it
when therapists actually make us think
wait where are we yeah why are we
triggered why are we reacting to this
she found out it was a her issue yeah
i've told her this but when it comes to
me it's not like an attack no no yes
this is not a me issue it's a you issue
i was like you need to figure what makes
you happy yeah i was like where what
what is the thing that drives your
happiness i can't make you happy your
happiness is your responsibility i'm
here i'm your bonus in your life i was
like at the end of the day if i
disappear are you sad all the time all
day i was like how can you how can you
base your happiness on what makes me
happy figure out what makes you tick and
you obviously that came man just like so
it's just my fault i'm like [ __ ] okay i
need a therapist to come in here
something you know and then when she had
her therapist come in she came looped
back and she goes you know what my
therapist told me they told me that it's
a me thing and i need to figure out what
makes me happy i was like you son of a
[ __ ] like i [ __ ]
i [ __ ] said the exact same thing i
don't [ __ ] it just doesn't hit the
same you [ __ ] with her [ __ ] not
saying i'll choke all of you out right
now i'm literally going to kill somebody
she's laugh at it now i remember when i
heard that i was like son of a [ __ ]
like i swear to god i'm gonna kill
somebody
but you know it takes that therapist to
come in and help them out yeah cause
you're so like ingrained in this like
love bubble and all you can see is like
what you see and sometimes someone needs
to pull you out and be like this is
what's happening like do you recognize
it that
that's the part too is just like uh i
think
what a therapist does that helps you out
it allows you to
say the things that you know you feel
without feeling the judgment so it
allows you to be more open that's so
real especially because they don't have
like personal ties with you exactly my
therapist like all right i'll see you
next month doesn't know what's happening
throughout the month until i see them
again exactly so there's like this weird
moment where i remember when i first
went to therapy years ago it was like oh
i know it's about myself but i don't
think i've ever said it out loud to
somebody and then saying it out loud
made me feel really good it's like oh
this happened because of this and i've
never told anybody else i only told
myself never told my brother my mom my
dad or anything else yeah and just
having somebody hear it made me feel
relieved i was like oh [ __ ] so why i
wonder why i can tell this person it's
like oh because they're not judging me
yeah that's so real i could say some of
the most embarrassing things that i feel
embarrassed about and this person can
hear it out and they won't have no
judgment like there's no facial reaction
there's no like oh my god this guy's
[ __ ] weird
i mean i was talking about it with my
friend too there's something special
about going to a therapist and knowing
like listen i'm not trying to tell you
this to make you cry yeah i'm just
telling you this because i need to get
it off my chest yeah and it's really
nice to talk to someone who won't cry
yeah i mean i know some people who have
made their therapist cry but for me it
just feels good to know it's not like
i'm you're going to feel bad for me
we're going to talk through this so for
me when i started seeing my therapist
was actually in the beginning of the
pandemic everything was fine to be
honest but i told myself i think this is
the time to go see a therapist so i can
establish a relationship with them
so i made a game plan with her i was
like listen there's a lot of things you
need to catch up on so i'm going to see
you six weeks in a row and then from
there we'll make a game plan on how
often i see you so now i've transitioned
to like once a month and it's something
that i talk about all the time because
it's not normalized yet even in our like
korean culture
our asian culture in general and um i
love the fact that i'm able to establish
something where i know i have a safe
place to go
yeah yeah yeah that's very important i
mean for you too like i've been seeing
you
uh
on your stories like you're talking a
lot about like health and fitness too
was that something that was spurred on
by pandemic no so that's why it's funny
because the pandemic happened around
like well you know we were all like on
lockdown starting march forward yeah but
um
i have
so i'm an actor and i booked my first tv
episode at the um
the end of december of 2019. yeah and
actually i was at the heaviest that i
had ever been on my weight okay i was
the heaviest but i was happy
and for the longest time i was a theater
major i didn't pursue acting but there
was certain things like narratives in my
brain that said like you're not going to
be able to make it as an actor because
you look a certain way like you're not
like the tiny asian girl
um i've always had curves but then like
being in atlanta and georgia like i i
did go through depression a lot actually
because i didn't have any community i
barely knew the guy that i married of
course and so um
i had gained a lot of weight and i
didn't know how to
really decipher what health was for me
right because a lot of the narrative is
you're skinny you look good period
um but for me like i knew there had to
be more
um so i i hired a health coach in the
beginning of 2020 because i was like
sorry i'm like backtracking but with the
acting thing because i had gotten to
affirmation it's not about my weight
it's not about how i look if anything
that inspired me to be the healthiest
that i could be
because that didn't stop them from
booking me i still got the job yeah and
um it was like a big network it was hbo
you know and like to be able to say like
i got on hbo show being like how i
looked just as i was i felt really
accepted
so now i was like okay how can i live a
better longer life yeah so i hired a
health coach in the beginning of january
2020 and it was like a three-month thing
and i learned how to count macros for
the first time and at that point i had
regularly been working out but now i was
really just trying to work out to grow
strength i never grew up thinking like
muscles are important yeah you know like
instead of like losing weight like
losing fat being important
a lot of times people ask like oh what
weight do you want to be at this point i
say like i don't know whatever is like
like healthy for me where my body fat
percentage is lower
right um cause 130 pounds could look
different for other people like you know
depending on what their height is and
where they carry their weight naturally
also like women have to deal with
hormones all these things but i wanted
to learn what are macros how do you
count calories all these things and i
learned that so um in 2020 i
hired the therapist too
and i was able to
lose like 30 pounds
and people might be like oh you could
lose 20 pounds in two months no like i
really tried to do this the healthy way
and it was like a long process for me um
but i learned how to like strength train
join gyms that i love found things that
i loved
[Music]
[Music]
when i was young i was told that i
wasn't enough
[Music]
why even bother you won't get much
father give up
[Music]
they wanted way more than you they would
die trying would you what are you
willing to do
[Music]
well i just want to be free and be who i
meant to be but then the voices keep
telling me
if only you were
if only you were
if only you were
[Music]
if only you were
if only you were
if only you were
now that i'm grown i have learned that
there isn't one way
[Music]
there is no turning away from your feet
you are safe
[Music]
i'll take my time it's a gift make sure
there's nothing i miss this is the one
life i leave
i know that i can be free and be who i
meant to be but then the voices keep
telling me
if only you were if only you were if
only you
[Music]
were if only you were
if only you were
if only you were
[Music]
slimmer
prettier
thinner
taller smarter
prettier
thinner
taller
smarter
they've got wise much to say and yet so
little to show no i don't mean accolades
i mean the depths of your soul i'm doing
what i do best i mean that i'm doing me
that's what i mean when i say
i just wanna be
free
[Music]
i just wanna be
free
if only you were
if only you were
if only you were
if only you were
[Music]
if only you were
if only you were
if only you were i just wanna be free
[Music]
hold up my friends this podcast is
brought to you by ipvatish for those of
you who don't know ipvanish is a vpn or
a virtual private network that helps you
safely browse the internet simply put if
you are on a computer doing just about
anything and you don't have a vpn by
ipvanish you are insane and you need to
be locked up in a cuckoo house because
people and web snoopers are all up in
your business and you don't even know i
don't even know what you're doing but
other people do so what are you doing
not getting ipvanish circumvent any
online censorship and get protection
when using public wi-fi so basically
nobody can snoop on your data or see
what you're doing online so go to
ipvanish.com brainclaim your 65 savings
their annual plan is just 44.99 for the
first year with our exclusive discount
this is the time to sign up with our
discount and their current promotion you
can get a vpn for 65 off the usual
offering ipvanish is the best of the
best even rated 4.7 out of 5 on
trustpilot and that's with more than
6000 reviews my friends remember it's
ipvanish.combrain to get the deal and
start protecting yourself online and it
was a game changer for me and i think
that confidence also helped me continue
to get more auditions and book more jobs
i've gotten some co-star roles and books
on commercials and it went hand in hand
with me just feeling good with my body
yeah right because i still don't think i
look like the typical like asian star
that i see right now like in mainstream
media but the fact that i still get the
auditions i still get the callbacks like
i know that there's a chance for me and
it also makes me happy to be someone who
can
represent a different body type that
like isn't always a narrative yeah um
but i injured my back a couple months
ago from deadlifting i did it wrong and
so i had to work with a physical
therapist and i couldn't work out the
same and i realized that like my
physical health had become my
stress reliever too yeah and so i had to
battle with my mental health actually
when i couldn't work out the same
but i'm healed now shout out to
james at arc studio because he's a pt
and i never worked with a physical
therapist before yeah and like just
taking my time on how to heal my body
yeah so um i still work with him and
i've been working out again um and just
finding balance right like i think it's
so easy for uh
women
and especially like me growing up korean
i only have that personal experience of
like people just being like um
like oh you gained weight you lost
weight oh they love that [ __ ] yeah
that's like the only way they know how
to communicate yeah and like they don't
care about my health for real for real
you know like and i remember i had to
like talk back a few times being like
are you gonna pay for my gym membership
are you gonna pay for my groceries yeah
and they'd be like
how could you talk to me that way and
i'm just like because you're not going
to take responsibility for your words
yeah and in a way like i had to stand up
for myself because the moment i stand up
for myself i'm actually standing up for
other girls yeah because maybe that
person won't talk to someone else again
yeah you know
well it's just you know korean people
don't know boundaries very well right
and there's like a
there's like a hierarchy in age like
older people feel that they could say
whatever they want to a younger
generation because that's just how it is
in korea right they're
their level of communication is very odd
right specifically our our parents
generation
they tend to
communicate by pointing out something
that either they don't like or they feel
like you should change
right there's no tact it's just is what
it is i literally saw my dad once it was
this dude that i knew in sacramento he
hadn't seen or their family friends and
they hadn't seen his he hasn't seen
their daughter in a very long time
and she got a little chunky
right and the first thing he said off
the bat he goes
right and then she looks at him runs
into a room slams the door and i look at
my dad i'm like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you why did you say that right he
was like why she got fat and i'm like
doesn't [ __ ] matter i was like you
don't just say that [ __ ] i was like what
are you what are you talking about do
you like the fact that i'm yelling at
you right now i was like i still think
i'm right doesn't mean you should say it
he didn't understand he goes what the
problem is it's like if she doesn't want
to be fat then why is she fat i was like
cool it's like you don't want to go bald
but would you like if somebody kept on
calling you a [ __ ] temporary like how
do you like it you know and it's just
like it's different you know but he
doesn't understand it that's that's just
how these like older korean generation
people communicate
like my
so marilyn and i had
mariel tends to have this problem too
where she does it a lot and she doesn't
know that she does it yeah it's just
ingrained in us that's why we got into a
fight because i told her if you don't
like it when your mother does it to you
don't do it to me i was like don't make
comments about my appearance weight or
anything else because if we have kids i
would be damn sure that i will never
allow you to talk to them yeah cause
they're gonna hear that growing up yeah
and it's it's the very reason why it's
so easy for us to have those tendencies
because we've been told that girl yeah
and it's not her fault yeah she gets it
all the [ __ ] time and so it transfers
over so i just you know it's my trigger
that's my trigger and so because i hate
it i don't like it when people talk
about somebody's appearance in that kind
of sense unless it goes somewhere i was
like say something with a purpose yes
if it's hey you gain weight
is something going on in your life are
you stressed out like you i know you're
concerned about your health where does
this conversation go don't walk in the
room and be like gain weight walk out
what the [ __ ] like where where where is
this conversation going are you doing
this to help me are you doing this make
fun of me what's the purpose of this
yeah right and so i was like korean
people have a habit of that they like to
make comments about your parents but
what is the [ __ ] point why are you
going to pay for my gym membership are
you going to pay for my hospital what
are you going to do here yes but the
fact that you just came in here to make
this come and [ __ ] up my day up is where
we're gonna have an issue yeah you know
and i think a lot of korean kids they
deal with this this this crazy image
issue where they feel they have to look
a certain way they have to be a certain
way talk a certain way because if it's
not it's not socially acceptable you
become a social pariah if you are a fat
person if you don't have clear skin 24
[ __ ] seven it's just this weird weird
korean culture thing i don't understand
what the [ __ ] is about yeah and like
when it comes to like perfection and all
those things i think about how i've
learned so much about health especially
like going through like my own health
scare so like a few years ago i found
that i had like a pituitary gland tumor
which is like right here right and
luckily it was benign um how did you
find that out my optometrist because
like you could do eye test and if
there's a certain place that you can't
see there they actually encourage you to
go see a neurologist and
yeah oh wow so i had to go to emory and
everything and get like mri scans and
stuff but um i actually do have to get
it checked again but there's things
where it messes with your hormones right
and also a lot of women deal with pcos
like i've had very irregular periods
since i was young so it was never normal
for me to have regular periods and like
those things make a difference when it
comes to weight right but koreans aren't
going to talk about that they're not
going to ask you hey like how's your
health doing actually
they're just more concerned about what
your size is and or if they can't depict
that they'll find something wrong with
your face right
and also like asian women have the
highest chance of osteoporosis yeah and
they don't encourage
you know their women to like lift
weights and like do strength training
because they think it's just going to
make them bulkier so there's so many
things that we have to like disrupt of
things that we've grown up with and my
biggest fear with like k-pop being so
popularized is really just because like
we know that they work really hard and a
lot of them have to be manufactured in a
way where they look like perfect yeah
and it's a standard that we have to live
up to and i love like people being able
to have the choice of getting work done
if they want to it's their right they
could do whatever they want with their
body
but at the same time there's still like
this expectation of like do it if you
can do it if you want to but also people
don't have don't all have the money to
like get work done in korea it's like a
prize if you graduate high school you'll
get like um sanka processor which like
double eyelid surgery you know it's like
different things where we're we're
like i like i always
you know that topic of like
um
cosmetic surgery has always been a
little weird for me right because
there was a there was a weird paradigm
shift in terms of in terms of a word
usage when it comes to
the idea of plastic surgery being
acceptable or not right
and there's this idea of like your body
you do whatever the [ __ ] you want with
it right
which yeah i 100 agree with that too but
then there's another side of me where i
think like
one is enough right right right where is
that limit i have
i have very rarely seen somebody
do a certain like cosmetic surgery on
their face or whatever where it's like
drastic
and then they still feel amazing about
the way they look two years three years
four years five years six years from now
because typically what i've seen and i'm
saying this from somebody who lives in
los angeles yeah it might be different
elsewhere but in this city it's like
they get one thing done they do another
thing then another thing then another
thing and they get older and they forget
that when you age your face changes yeah
there's no there's just no idea of
giving them self grace like you age with
grace when you age things happen things
change this thing is not forever right
you're putting an investment in
something that's that literally
is not going to stay around and i think
that's a hard thing for a lot of people
to accept and they're kind of banking on
this idea that oh if i just change this
one thing i'm going to be happy for the
rest of my life
and look like i said your face
do whatever the [ __ ] you want with it
but
i think there should be a time for you
to reflect on like okay if i do get this
done is it gonna change how i feel about
myself yeah the whole time and i
have not seen it yet so in in terms of
this city because there's a lot of
pressure here to look a certain way like
this the standard of beauty is becoming
so
singular now everybody looks the same
yeah on tick-tock because there's a
popular look yeah and it's and it's just
easier because the internet like these
girls have to look a certain way they
need bigger lips they need uh bigger
eyes they need their hair done a certain
way oh my gosh the bbl videos on tick
tock are rampant it's [ __ ] and it's
really dangerous actually so definitely
you know
it's just like how come people can't
look different like
that's the beauty of being human like
you get to look different and
somebody will find you attractive
there's people who find you beautiful
things that are beautiful here aren't
beautiful somewhere else but now all
that's starting to become singular it's
like you have to look this way it's the
kim kardashian look it's the kardashian
thing and it's like well who's who sets
the standard for beauty like who the
[ __ ] says that person is beautiful the
other person's not yeah you know like i
understand you know there's a general
standard for beauty when it comes to
symmetry and whatever what not sure but
at the same time it's like why do you
want to look like everybody else yeah
like why is this the most important
thing in your life i think the
representation thing like there is
something about like constantly seeing
an image and feeling like oh i guess
that's how i have to look yeah if i want
to be accepted
um or given a chance yeah
is is there something that when you were
younger that you wanted to like
cosmetically change about yourself it
was really always about weight oh really
always about weight yeah because like
you know i have double eyelids like my
family has it and like um
it's that would be like the main thing
that a lot of my friends have gotten so
they would think like oh she she has
tango food but she she's fat so it
doesn't matter you know what i mean but
i didn't understand the the thing like
what's what's so what's so attractive
about it it has to be like the big eyes
westernized thing oh is that what it is
i feel like it has to be like i don't
know i didn't have like figures i still
don't get it till this day it's like
that person has two eyelids and who the
[ __ ] cares yeah it's like
i was like all right i don't think a guy
ever looked at a girl's face and was
like damn i mean i think about like a
lot of the korean surgeries that are
popularized are like western beauty
standards right even like wanting to be
like lighter skinned and like having
like a nose bridge that's very high um
big lips thing right yeah yeah yeah um
but there's something really beautiful
about being able to see like different
faces but we're like just starting to
see like different types of asians on
television yeah right
it's it's it's a weird space because
like every time i go to a korean
barbecue restaurant and i see a girl
group i'm like you know you know who did
work or who didn't yeah and they all did
work and i'm just looking at them like
which one are you are you the group that
was before or after yeah and i didn't
know that they're all three different
girl groups because they all look
exactly the [ __ ] same it's so weird
yeah and then people idolize that stuff
they go i wanna look like that like
who's her surgeon because then after a
certain point it becomes a status of
wealth
like i have the ability to look this way
i heard people get like their graduation
gift is like yeah surgery yeah exactly
that's so weird like what [ __ ]
parents are these like why yeah because
i think they also think like the world
will be um kinder to them if they look a
certain way probably in the society that
they live in they they really care about
it a lot yeah oh my god man i can't even
imagine what it's like to live like that
yeah like to be constantly on edge
because you're always worried about what
somebody else thinks about the way you
look and behave it's too hard man and
you know like the singing competition
shows like i don't know about superstar
k because i didn't go on for that long
but i know of friends who have gone on
other shows and it would be in their
written contract that if they get to a
certain point that they have the right
to make them get work done that's
[ __ ] crazy
and people sign it they're like okay yes
because they're so excited for that
opportunity oh this is the gateway this
is how i'm gonna find success when in
reality like you never know what will
happen to your career you could be the
most talented person and like have a hit
longevity is the hardest thing to have
that continuation of course but we were
talking about this earlier today too
it's like nobody thinks about the long
game they do not yeah they they they
constantly think about okay how can i
pop off now and they disappeared three
or four years later and they hold on to
this idea of what they were before yeah
people think too much about their their
husbands like okay i used to be this i
used to be that it's like who the [ __ ]
are you now yeah yeah but can i say
something i really want y'all to know
that the reason why i love david so much
is because from day one he's always
treated me the same to this day and i've
always felt like you know there was a
moment when i had um
i don't know more viewers or whatever on
youtube and stuff and for me i was very
young trying to navigate what that meant
for me yeah and i could tell like
people's way of treating me changed and
i'm really glad
yeah but i'm grateful that i went
through that at a younger age because
now that like i have some you know wins
that are for me like other people might
not think it's a big one but for me it
is and for like people like you to treat
me the same like i know who's for me and
who isn't for me well those type of
people too they are also the ones that
don't last in this space yeah i know
those people and they've lasted a very
short time because how you treat
everybody how you treat one person is
how you treat everybody and that's how
it is and you see them now and all these
people they're all [ __ ] husbands and
now they're now they're feeling the
repercussions of not being in that
position anymore and they're like oh
people aren't hitting me up well you
never connected you never made a deeper
level yeah like it has to be pangawa
which is like very nice to see someone
but it's not nice to see someone who
maybe treated you like crap because you
just weren't who they thought they
wanted oh yeah they stopped picking up
your phone calls as much suddenly you're
not having lunch anymore you have
nothing to talk about and connect to
it's like well i thought this was a real
friendship it was like no you wanted to
get something from me and that because
you received it it was good but the
moment i couldn't help elevate your
career we were pretty much done here
yeah right and that's the annoying thing
it's like well you're a piece of [ __ ]
and you will forever be a piece of [ __ ]
and you're going to be lonely for the
rest of your life i don't say that in a
spiteful way i say this as a [ __ ]
fact i see it so many [ __ ] times and
i've told the story before where i had
somebody who did that [ __ ] to me and it
only happened once
he met up with me after and he was like
hey bro it's really good seeing you i'm
seeing you i missed you i was like bro i
never thought about you once get the
[ __ ] away from me yeah it's like i'm
glad that i'm here in the same space
that you happen to be in at this party
too but you're only here because your
girlfriend was here not because of your
talent so get the [ __ ] away from me
there's really something to be said
about continuing to do work
even if no one is applauding you yeah
yeah because you know like it's either
something you're supposed to do you're
called to do and there are going to be
times like if you're working on
something there are going to be times
where it feels like it's not going as
well as you want it to but if you keep
pushing through and you're still doing
it like at least you can say you're
doing it for yourself yeah i think doing
it for yourself is always going to be
the the best way to sustain
doing an art because like it's for you
it's for your gratification yeah you do
it for yourself first so when criticism
comes to it you liked it and that's what
matters at the end of the day totally
because it would suck if you sold your
soul out and then still everybody hated
it yeah then what the [ __ ] was the point
yeah you know what i mean you did
something to please everybody else and
they hated your work after you're left
with absolutely [ __ ] nothing it
happens way too often in this industry i
see you no i applaud you for sticking it
out and like being here still because i
was like i gotta go i gotta go to
georgia and be nice around nice southern
people
like i'm here i mean but i've kept the
same friends yeah like i don't i don't
go to a lot of parties i don't really
like schmooze like that if i [ __ ] with
them i [ __ ] with them yeah a lot of
times i don't get invited out to things
because they know if i don't like them
it's no i mean it's real like even when
i lived in l.a like there are very few
people who i actually felt comfortable
being with yeah whether because like i
didn't want to have to play the game
yeah like can i just like live and like
be myself but you guys here too like the
people that i really really dislike that
i always talk [ __ ] about on this podcast
you don't hear them saying anything back
because they know i know everything
about them it's like i know it's like
you could talk [ __ ] back if you want if
you want to get [ __ ] eaten up let's
go you know what i mean and you know
there's a couple of [ __ ] youtubers i
always make fun of on this podcast
because they are those type of people
yeah they're [ __ ] habitual uh uh
ladder steppers they step on people to
get where they're at and they still
haven't gone anywhere you know it's like
so funny because i think about when i
was younger there'd be people who i felt
like were actually like mean and like
cruel to me and i would see them
thriving and i'd be like life is not
fair i don't want to do this anymore but
fast forward to now like me being an
adult
i'm just like oh they're still
everyone's at the same place they're
still at the same [ __ ] yeah and not any
happier and if anything with less
friends yeah less friends and they still
complain and [ __ ] about life all the
[ __ ] time
like i've had to cut so many [ __ ]
people out and it felt so good and they
don't understand why they're like well i
thought
no i was like no you were around me
because you thought you could take from
me right and i just got tired of you
taking and then me receiving nothing so
now you be on your own and you find the
next sucker that you're going to
befriend and they'll find out about you
and then you'll lose them again too and
i see it and i keep because people
gossip all the time yes and i get these
calls that hey you're right i told you
that three years ago bro what do you
want me to do i warned you it is what it
is move the [ __ ] on man yeah and i see
it so often and it makes me sad it makes
me sad because like
you kind of pity people like that
because they're trying so hard i can
give you a great example so like um
a couple of dudes that listen i don't
have anything personally against him
like that but i hate everything about
them who they are how they treat people
how they behave where gets around yeah
how you treat one person is how you
treat everybody else and trust me that
one person when they speak ill of you
turns out to be 10 13 15 or 14 because
all those people will start to piece
these stories together yeah right
because they wouldn't dare do that to me
i'd [ __ ] beat their [ __ ] ass i'd
literally beat the [ __ ] out of them
but
you know with these people like it got
to a point where he asked um
one of my friends he's like hey can you
tell me why david hates me so much oh my
gosh
he was texting me he goes bro this guy
is like sad saying like hey can you ask
ask him why he hates me so much i was
like just tell him this just tell him i
don't [ __ ] with you and the way that you
carry yourself word gets around and i
was like you and tell him that he he
should already know why i don't [ __ ]
with him and that a majority of people
that's around him they don't [ __ ] with
them either i'm just more vocal about it
yeah so i'm just not the one that you
ever want to come near because i will
[ __ ] wreck you right and i and then
he knows
he knows it he's like oh [ __ ] he knows
all the stuff about me who doesn't
everybody talks i literally don't know
how some people sleep at night yeah like
why do you think people won't talk yeah
and it's it's consistent with like 30
people so it's like come on you've
literally [ __ ] people over you treat
people like [ __ ] [ __ ] what did you
think was going to happen no i think
they're kind of delusional in the
beginning like oh i'm getting away with
them getting away with it and then
eventually it adds up and they're like
oh no no one's left around standing with
me i talk about like these [ __ ] like
because recently because of a lot of the
asian hate stuff people are being very
vocal about it i talk about a lot of
these self-serving asian actors where
they're only doing it because they're
trying to gain the clout and they want
to be a part of this stuff well guess
what a lot of this just been happening
for [ __ ] years but now you're getting
this cloud and you know what i don't
even mind keep doing it because it's
good like whatever you're doing is still
good but i told the story in the last
podcast where i know a very specific
actor very popular asian actor he was
slated to do this uh asian-american
thing against asian hate but he wasn't
slated as one of the first built top
build actors to do it so he refused to
share it on social media it's like
that's funny you were
for the past year you were talking about
how asian people don't have enough
representation how people don't do
things from the goodness of their heart
[ __ ] word gets around you didn't
promote that thing because you weren't
one of the first people up on that video
it's like you're trash
and i've been saying it about this guy
since the first day i met him i was like
something's off about this fool and he's
very self-serving people are like yo
he's a great person he does stuff for i
was like no he doesn't i can tell you
could smell it off somebody yeah and
they're doing it for the wrong reason i
think when you do it long enough you can
tell yeah when you've seen it so often
yeah it's like i've seen this person
this type of person so [ __ ] often you
could smell it and now word's getting
around around small little hollywood and
they're like yeah he's kind of an
[ __ ] what i tell you guys like two
years ago
you know
it's just sad i just hate it so much and
it's like because in this space too
i don't have a night i don't have a want
to be famous it keeps me very clear yeah
i get that when i do something what
people consider big like i did a netflix
show like we should go celebrate i'm
like why it's cool
well i did the show i'm gonna work on
another project later on [ __ ] move on
right there's nothing it's not that i'm
not giving myself a pat on the back i
don't like putting myself in a position
where i have to glorify myself because
this was fun for me yeah you don't have
to congratulate me i appreciate the
congratulations it feels good that my
friends care enough to do that but i
don't need a spotlight on me because who
cares
like what you do is great what i do is
great too yeah why can't we celebrate
your wins because what it was on netflix
i could celebrate your [ __ ] win how
come we don't celebrate the [ __ ] that
you do just because it's not a [ __ ]
tv what the [ __ ] cares yeah like that's
that's the weird part it's like every
time i do a project and they go oh this
is a big deal i was like well you just
had a kid that's a pretty big [ __ ]
deal why don't we celebrate that too if
we want to celebrate this then we have
to go and celebrate your [ __ ] too
because i'm not going to just do this
for me we got to do stuff for you too
then yeah you know because it's this is
what people put value in no it that's so
real and i think your heart is in the
right place because when we think about
how like media is it's because the
spotlight's there right it's so like in
everyone's face whereas like the work
our friends who may not be in the
entertainment industry are in like we
don't know what they're doing day to day
we don't know their wins we don't get to
celebrate it the same and that's also
where like social media can become very
toxic because it's always like the
highlight reel and you see everyone
doing all these big things
um but to be able to like step away and
be like yeah it is something to
celebrate but it doesn't have to be any
more special than someone else getting a
promotion at another job so like when
somebody you know when like like even
when [ __ ] happened right like oh let's
go andre that's like cool but what did
you do it's like oh i did well let's go
celebrate that all together and then we
would just have a party and we would
just kind of like you know basically
suck each other's dick off you know like
yeah you know what i mean yeah you did
that yeah you did that yeah you did that
you know and it feels good it needs to
be reciprocated though i don't i don't i
don't really like that because that
success is temporary yeah and i think it
would be actually really exhausting to
be with a group of friends that only
celebrate you
when you have like
wins that are like popular exactly
because then you're just having to feel
like what's my next thing what's my next
thing yeah so i'd really
you know we could even go on the topic
of like relevancy right like
one of the weirdest insults that young
people do it's like oh you're not even
relevant anymore right it's like who
cares yeah it's like who the [ __ ] cares
it's like is that what you think that i
did this for you thought that i did this
because i wanted to be in my name to be
in everybody's [ __ ] mouth right it's
like you and i have a very different
life goal like i care about my personal
legacy and how i feel about it when i
say legacy too i'm not talking about
what other people say about me it's
about how i feel about myself before i
die and so that's my main goal in life
yeah so don't put your [ __ ] on me not at
all a psych yeah when i was younger i
was doing so many youtube videos
smoothing and doing all this other [ __ ]
and then i stopped doing youtube for a
couple years because i wanted to
disappear yeah i get that i mean same i
there were like years when i just wasn't
online anymore yeah and it felt good
yeah you know it's like this felt good
and i came back when i felt like i
wanted to come back and i did the
podcast instead you come back with like
a clearer mind oh a hundred percent yeah
it feels good and i think like i'm
trying to like teeter this
um this area of uh
garnering a viewership that i want right
yeah so they well you could do this and
get more views but i'm like i don't want
those fans though
i don't want the fan base that comes
from this person so no i don't want to
do a podcast with them yeah oh but it'll
make your podcast bigger i don't care
about it being bigger i like garnering
the audience that i have
and curating a great supportive group
yeah that's it yeah if i can get more
viewership from somebody i don't like i
don't want their followers they don't
know me they don't know us they don't
know these viewers on this podcast
either they don't know them the way that
you know them exactly yeah it's like you
cannot come on this podcast i'm sorry i
don't give a [ __ ] about your personal
life i've had a lot of people asking
like i want you can you get this guy on
and then some people are like hey can
you have this guy on and i'm like you
are the most boring human being i've
ever met why the [ __ ] would i want to
hear your story
like your story is useless like
your story is your story it's it's
valuable but not to me right right and
this is your space yeah exactly it's my
space and you created your space by like
really thinking about like what do i
want exactly what do you want you know
and it's like i don't want to hear about
how you did a dance on tick tock and it
blew up yeah like i know the story it's
done what else and a lot of times too
it's like
like i've scratched a lot of podcasts
that people won't see because i've
interviewed people where they were the
worst storytellers on earth because they
have not lived life they don't know
anything and they want me they want to
do a podcast i was like why do you want
to do a podcast when you have no life
experience no opinions and no thoughts
yeah what are we going to talk about it
was literally me talking and this person
just going uh-huh
uh-huh i'm like this is you this is
about you where are your stories what do
you have to tell me what do you
experience what did you where did you
grow up it's like oh i grew up in
michigan
and you know it's like bro what the [ __ ]
am i what are you doing here and that's
when i cut it out i was like no more i'm
only bringing friends yeah i'm like i'm
only bringing friends onto this podcast
i think it's really important for people
to have lived life and like really gone
through some hard [ __ ] yeah it's
important it's character building like i
do these ig lives now where i give like
my thoughts uh like some life advice i
wouldn't have been able to do that 10
years ago yeah like because i had i
didn't live yeah what can i tell you
it's like hey dude i'm going through my
family problems like cool i actually
hate my parents too
yeah i i had nothing to tell you yeah
you know so i just started doing like
life and creative coaching and i found
it as today worthy because i think about
like when i first started posting on
youtube i was 17 years old youtube super
young yeah youtube wasn't what it was
like
i always joke like i got on too early i
didn't know what the hell i was doing i
didn't make any money off of youtube i
know like people make a good living off
of it but for me it was really just i
wanted to sing
and like from there like a lot of
ridicule like dealing with all these
things of popularity and like how you
look etc but like fast forward to now
like with today worthy i wanted people
to know like you're worthy today like
whether or not someone says like you're
valuable whether or not your video goes
viral or whether or not you get that
promotion like you're here so you matter
so a lot of the
clients that i work with i'm able to
talk to them about things because i've
experienced those hardships too you know
a lot of women that i work with like
struggle with their body image yeah and
like where it comes from and i get to
say like i understand
and like i wish i had someone who could
talk to me about that because
i always felt like i was the ostracized
one i was the fat girl of the group or
whatever
um
and to be able to relate on like the
things that they've struggled with with
their parents you know like our parents
say things they love us but that doesn't
mean the things they say are always the
best things yeah and also like as
creatives because i work with also the
creatives of my clients and like um i
have to let them know like listen even
if you launch this even if nobody buys
it the first day are you gonna still
think it's a success yeah and i have to
ask them because whenever i list like
release a song or do a project even if
nobody listens to it i'm good yeah and
that took time because there was a time
when i would like easily upload a video
to get 10 000 views in a day and then
one day it just became like 200 views a
day yeah and that crushed me of course
you know it crushed me but now i can
like upload things without being like
dude it is what it is like i'm still
alive today which is pretty cool because
at one point i didn't think i would be
that's like dave chappelle's level [ __ ]
like you just put it out and you just
see what happens who [ __ ] cares yeah
if you're doing it for yourself that's
all that really matters now obviously if
you need to make a living you have to go
make a living yes but if you're doing it
for fun and you're truly saying you're
doing it for fun then have fun with it
no and i really want to emphasize like
the fact that you have such an
entrepreneurial spirit is so refreshing
because when i was younger i always felt
like if i'm not doing music full time
then i'm not a real musician just
because of the way that people would
talk to me oh you're not like a
full-time youtuber making money that way
like um you're no you're a nobody like
you're not actually doing it yeah but
that was just in my circumstance i had
to hustle i had to work all these jobs
and like still like do what i love and
that translated well as a grown-up now
like i juggle a lot of things but i'm
happy i'm doing all these things and
having to but i provide for myself i'm
not asking anyone for money i'm working
and like so is my husband and we're
figuring how to live a creative life
yeah and like that to me is success like
we get to go to bed knowing like we're
doing what we love even if it might not
be in the scale that someone else is
expecting but we know where we started
well yeah i mean like
[ __ ] what everybody else thinks it's
like what do you expect out of your life
yeah you know i've seen people who have
literally a quarter of the amount that i
have in their way they were way happier
than i was like when a few years ago
before i had my paradigm shift of losing
weight and then kind of like figuring
out what made me happy yeah they had
something figured out that i didn't have
yeah i'm not saying rich people aren't
happy right but they're happy in what
they do there are some people who are
hyper materialistic and i don't even
mean that in a bad way buying dope [ __ ]
makes them happy cool that's your lane
doesn't mean it has to be mine yeah this
this constant just
comparison game thing [ __ ] people up so
much because you're so busy looking into
somebody else's pockets you can't
appreciate the [ __ ] that you have so
real it's so hard to live that way you
know the grass is green or where you
water it yeah my mom she's worked so
hard her whole life she's i've never
heard her say once i hate my life i've
never heard that and i honestly think
that's probably where i got my [ __ ] from
too because no matter how poor we were
how much they were fighting how i wasn't
the greatest kid she never said [ __ ] my
life i hate my life she's never ever
said those words and so now i get it
it's like and i even ask her now what
would you have done differently she goes
nothing what would i have done
differently she goes even till this day
she still likes working at the store
it's hard work but she goes this is the
thing that put a roof over our head make
sure that you guys were okay so i
appreciate this i see my same customers
i've seen for 30 years and this makes me
happy a lot of people look at what i
have and say that i don't have much or
it's like they say oh she works so hard
she goes what's so hard i love working
here what's the problem and that's the
difference like it's perspective is
everything she chooses to live the life
that she wants and this is the choices
that she makes and she [ __ ] loves it
she never looks at somebody else's home
and says i wish i had their home yeah
she never looks at somebody else's car
says i wish i had their car she goes i
have what i have this is great we're all
going to die we're all going to go into
this [ __ ] earth one one day or not
doesn't really matter no matter how much
they make or whatever they do they're
still going to end up the same as me
yeah i mean i have to be frank like the
most uh depressed time that i had was
probably when i felt like i was working
so much just to keep up with the joneses
yeah and like being in la like i had to
support myself i wasn't living at home
with my family like my mom if anything i
had to send her money and like trying to
figure it out being like oh i wish my
life was different i wish i could just
focus i wish i wish i sure i could keep
wishing yeah but the fact of the matter
is like that's not my life so what am i
gonna do about it yeah and i had to make
changes and there was yeah and there was
a point where like i didn't think i was
gonna do music anymore and that was okay
like i was okay with that
i was like you know what like i know
like music is a gift of mine but it's
not paying the bills right now and i
need to walk away from it
and figure it out
and i like worked out a startup learned
a lot if anything could help me but it
also helped me realize like oh maybe i'm
not done with music yeah but i don't
have to suffocate my art to make money
so i'm like happy to say i still do
music but i don't have to come out with
music all the time
because i'm not suffocating it right now
i'm living life i was just talking to
you about how i listen to podcasts more
than i do music yeah sorry if you think
that doesn't make me a real musician but
like i need to live life if i'm going to
write about it and sing about it and
like this is a season in my life where
other opportunities are coming for me
but i know like i've done music long
enough that like people know what i'm
about yeah people know that i will sing
and i will write and there are other
parts of me that i'm also embracing
because i get one life yeah and i need
to be able to say like i'm gonna try
um i don't know like if i'm gonna meet
the success that other people say but
i'm a success in myself knowing that
like i didn't think i'd be doing the
things like half the things i'm doing
now like i even had this conversation
with a buddy of mine where he was like
hey like
what are your backup plans if you look
like youtube doesn't happen and i'm like
don't get [ __ ] yeah i mean i was like
who cares yeah i was like there's no i
was like i don't think you understand
how poor i grew up like yes i am never
like above a job like if i need to make
money to pay these bills i'll do
whatever the [ __ ] i can yeah i'll suck
your dick right now let's go you know
not that far
i'll suck your dick right now give me
two thousand dollars i'll [ __ ] make
you come in 30 seconds like i'm not
beneath like
above any job yes i was like if during
like 10 years ago when all i had no
i wasn't making money then like seven
years ago like i youtube disappeared
guess what i would be applying jobs like
nothing sure everywhere and anywhere
yeah doesn't [ __ ] matter i'll be at
work like aren't you that youtuber i am
i'm poor now yeah and i'll work a job
yeah like when i was on youtube and
stuff i was still working at like boba
shops yeah and they'd be like oh my gosh
aren't you jennifer chung yeah you're
working i'm like yeah because i got to
pay the bills yeah like you're not
buying my music enough you know like i
need to i need to work yeah like we that
is what it is people are so prideful
about [ __ ] like that it's like you look
so so i wonder what you think about
everybody else in the service industry i
was like dude i grew up it's the hardest
work it's hard yeah it's hard that's why
even like and i'm pretty sure anybody
who's worked at like you know junebe
match and stuff too we really curate a
good family out there we care about the
employees we ask how they're doing we
make sure that they feel good we give
them good highs we let we let the good
highs like that's all it is hi no we no
we uh you know we show that they're that
they're there like we we show you exist
they're valued they're valued so like
i understand what it's like i worked in
service industry my whole life my
parents i had to run my parents store
all the time we had to run that business
all like 24 7. i did that since i was
like [ __ ] 12. so it's like i
understand the value of what work is
this
the fact that i even get to have a house
is like i get to i rent out this house
or whatever what not is a bonus this is
all a blessing my parents couldn't do
this before yeah like well setting your
own schedule exactly i could wake up
whatever the [ __ ] i want you know i do
have to work a lot but i can set when i
work and like yeah let's let's be clear
like the work that you do is hard work
like people see the stuff online and
they're like i want to do that yeah but
it's like do you know what it takes to
do that yeah you ain't ready for that
[ __ ] yeah it's [ __ ] hard work yeah
but at the same time to me i don't ever
call it hard work because i enjoy what
i'm doing
it's hard work yeah that's really what
it is it's like how
i don't complain
and you'll never hear me complain about
my work i don't and anybody can say this
too like if you've seen any of my videos
whether it was on jk news or mine i
never ever ever complain about my work
because i have nothing to complain about
yeah it's a lot of work it's a lot of
work trying to figure out how to run all
these businesses and you know promote
and market all this stuff and then make
sure it's stable and it's working i'm
working on a software store next year
we're working up uh we're on we're in
the process of opening up a junior in
hawaii right now this is work this takes
time however because i enjoy it not so
bad
because i could be doing something else
i could be doing something i don't want
to do
so
i never complain my mom never complained
about it work i have nothing to complain
about either yeah you know and that
shows in like the products that you
produce and um being able to find people
who are aligned with you when it comes
to building something together oh 100
yeah well [ __ ] well guys that wraps up
this episode of the genius brain podcast
jennifer where can they catch you oh
well you can find me online just on
instagram it's jennifer j chung find my
music jennifer chung maybe you'll see me
on some shows let's pray that i get some
some more rules oh she'll you'll see
you'll see her everywhere and then um
you can catch us uh junior spring every
thursdays and sundays hope you guys
learned a little bit about jennifer
today and some very cool thoughts and
we'll see you all next time
peace
[Music]
the river flows one direction
[Music]
and fishes they follow the flow
[Music]
but what if one tried to mention
that there was much
[Music]
here
[Music]
a dragonfly heard the message
darkness was home from the start
[Music]
spread its wings to the surface
the bright colors set them apart
here i am i have a plan i'm live
[Music]
here i am i have a plan i'm living free
don't know where
[Music]
don't know where i am
here i am i have a plan i'm living free
don't know where i am
[Music]
here i am
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]